so i've got an arbitrary triangle here
we'll call it triangle abc and what i
want to do is look at the midpoints of
each of the sides of abc so this is the
midpoint of one of the sides of side bc
let's call that point d
let's call this midpoint e
and let's call this midpoint right over
here f and since it's the midpoint we
know that the distance between b d is
equal to the distance from d to c so
this distance is equal to this distance
we know that ae is equal to ec so this
distance is equal to that distance and
we know that af is equal to fb so this
distance is equal to this distance
instead of drawing medians going from
these midpoints to the vertices what i
want to do is i want to connect these
midpoints and see what happens so if i
connect them i clearly have three points
so if you connect three non-linear
points like this
you will get another triangle
and this triangle that's formed from the
midpoint of the sides of this larger
triangle we call this a medial triangle
medial
triangle and that's all nice and cute by
itself but we're going to see in this
video is that the medial triangle
actually has some very neat properties
what we're actually going to show is
that it divides any triangle into four
smaller triangles that are congruent to
each other that all four of these
triangles are are identical to each
other and they're all similar to the
larger triangle and you could think of
them each has having one-fourth of the
area of the larger triangle so let's go
about proving it so first let's focus on
this triangle down here triangle c d e
and it looks it looks similar to the
larger triangle the triangle cba but
let's prove it to ourselves so one thing
we can say is well look both of them
share this angle right over here both
the larger triangle triangle c ba shares
has this angle and the smaller triangle
c d e has this angle so they definitely
share that angle
and then let's think about the ratios of
the sides we know that the ratio c d
we know that the ratio of c d
to c b
the ratio c d to c b
is equal to one over two this is half of
this entire side is equal to one over
two and that's the same thing as the
ratio of c e to c a c e is exactly half
of c a it's because e is the midpoint
it's equal to c e
over c a so we have an angle in
corresponding angles that are congruent
and then the ratios of two corresponding
sides on either side of that angle are
the same c d over c b is one half c e
over c a is one half and the angle in
between is congruent so by sas
so by sas similarity
sas similarity similarity
we know
we know that triangle
c d e
is similar to triangle to triangle
c b a
c
b a and just from that you can get some
interesting results because then we know
that the ratio of this side of the
shorter try of the smaller triangle to
the longer triangle is also going to be
one half because the other two sides
have a ratio of one half and we're
dealing with similar triangles so this
is going to be one half of that and we
know one half of a b is just going to be
is just going to be the length of fa so
we know that this length right over here
is going to be the same as fa or fb and
we get that straight from similar
triangles because these are similar
we know that d e
d e
over
b a
over b a has got to be equal to these
ratios the other corresponding sides
which is equal to one-half and so that's
how we got that right over there
now let's think about let's think about
this triangle up here let's think about
this triangle up here triangle we could
call it
bdf triangle bdf so first of all if you
compare triangle bdf to the larger
triangle they both share this angle
right over here angle abc they both have
that angle in common and we're going to
have the exact same argument we can
you can just look at this diagram you
know that the ratio of
b a
the ratio let me do this way the ratio
of bf to ba
the ratio of bf to ba is equal to
one-half which is also the ratio of bd
to bc
b
d
to b c
the ratio of this to that is the same as
the ratio of this to that which is one
half because bd is half of this whole
length bf is half of that whole length
and so you have corresponding sides have
the same ratio on the two triangles and
they share an angle in between so once
again by sas similarity
by sas similarity
s a s similarity
we know that triangle
we know that triangle i'll write this
way d
d
b f
triangle d
b
f
is similar to triangle c
b a
b a and once again we use this exact
same kind of argument that we did with
this triangle well if it's similar the
ratio of all the corresponding sides
have to be the same and that ratio is
one-half so the ratio of this side to
this side the ratio of f d the ratio of
f d to a c has to be one half or f d has
to be one half of a c which when one
half of a c is just the length of a e so
that is just going to be that length
right over there i think you see where
this is going and also because it's
similar all of the corresponding angles
have to be the same and we know this
that that the larger triangle has a
yellow angle right over there so we'd
have that yellow angle right over here
and this triangle right over here was
also similar to the larger triangle so
it will have that same angle measure up
here we already showed that in this in
this first part so now let's go to this
third triangle i think you see the
pattern i'm sure you might be able to
just pause this video and prove it for
yourself
but we see that the ratio of
a f
over a b
is going to be the same as the ratio of
a e
over a c a e over a c which is equal to
one half so we have two corresponding
sides where the ratio is one-half from
the smaller to the larger triangle and
they share a common angle they share
this angle in between the two sides so
by sas similarity this is getting
repetitive now we know that triangle we
know that triangle e f a
triangle e
f a
is similar to triangle c b a to triangle
c b a
and so the ratio all of the
corresponding sides need to be one half
so the ratio of f e to b c needs to be
one half our f e needs to be half of
that which is just the length of b d so
this is just going to be that length
right over there
now and you can also say that since
we've shown that all that this triangle
this triangle and this triangle we
haven't talked about this middle one yet
they are all similar to the larger
triangle so they're also all going to be
similar to each other so they're all
going to have the same corresponding
angles
so if the larger triangle had this
yellow angle here then all of the
triangles are going to have this yellow
angle right over there if the larger
triangle had this blue angle right over
here then in the corresponding vertex
all of the triangles are going to have
that blue angle
all of the ones that we've shown are
similar we haven't thought about this
middle triangle just yet and of course
if this is similar to the hole it'll
also have this angle at at this vertex
right over here because this corresponds
to that vertex based on the similarity
so that's interesting now let's look at
the let's look at let's compare the
triangles to each other we've now shown
that all of these triangles have the
exact same three sides has this blue
side or actually i don't know this one
marked side this two marked side and
this three marked side one mark two mark
three mark one mark two mark three mark
and that even applies to this middle
triangle right over here so by side side
side so by
by side side side congruency congruency
we now know and we want to be careful to
get our corresponding sides right we now
know that triangle triangle c d e
is congruent to triangle d
to d b f
d b f i want to get the corresponding
sides i'm looking at the colors i went
from yellow to magenta to blue yellow
magenta to blue which is going to be
congruent to triangle
to triangle e f a
e
f a which is going to be congruent to
this triangle in here but we want to
make sure that we're getting we're
getting the right corresponding sides
here so to make sure we do that we just
have to think about the angles so we
know we know and this is interesting
that the the because the the interior
angles of a triangle add up to 180
degrees we know this magenta angle plus
this blue angle plus this yellow angle
equal 180. here we have the blue angle
and the magenta angle and clearly they
will all add up to 180 so you must have
the blue angle the blue angle must be
right over here same argument blue angle
sorry yellow angle and blue angle we
must have the magenta angle right over
here they add up to 180 so this must be
the magenta angle and then finally
magenta and blue this must be the yellow
angle right over there and so when we
wrote the congruency here we started at
c d e we went yellow magenta blue so
over here we're going to go yellow
magenta blue so it's going to be
congruent to triangle f
e
d
to triangle f
e
d and so that's pretty cool we just
showed that all three that this triangle
this triangle this triangle and that
triangle are congruent and also we can
look at the corresponding and that they
all have ratios relative to the lar
they're all similar to the larger
triangle to triangle abc and that the
ratio between the sides is one to two
and also because we've looked at
corresponding angles we see for example
we see for example that
this angle is the same as that angle so
if you viewed dc or if you viewed bc as
a transversal all of a sudden it becomes
pretty clear that fd is going to be
parallel to ac because the corresponding
angles are congruent so this is going to
be parallel to that right over there and
then you could use that same exact
argument to say well then this side
because once again corresponding angles
corresponding angles here and here you
could say that this
is going to be parallel to that
right over there and then finally make
the same argument over here you have
you have want to make sure i get the
right corresponding angles you have this
this line and this line and this angle
corresponds to that angle they're the
same so this
d e
must be parallel to b a
to b a so that's another neat property
of this medial triangle i thought
all of these things just jump out when
you just try to do something fairly
simple with a with a triangle